>> Sean: LIKE I HAVE BEEN
SAYING NIGHT AFTER NIGHT COME A
BRAND-NEW FAR LEFT RADICALISM IS
NOW GRIPPING THE SOCIALIST
DEMOCRATIC PARTY IN THIS
COUNTRY, THEY WANT TO ABOLISH
I.C.E., OPEN BORDERS, BASELESS
MERE JOBS, THE NEW LEFT
COMMITTED TO DESTROYING THE
PRESIDENT AND HIS
AGENDA AND IN THE PROCESS THAT
WOULD MEAN YOUR PROSPERITY AT
ALL COSTS.
THAT IS NOT ONE OF THEIR
PRIORITIES.
JOINING US NOW TO TALK ABOUT
THIS AND MUCH MORE, CALL IN THE
GREAT ONE.
AT THE HOST OF THE NUMBER ONE
SHOW SUNDAY NIGHT IT'S 10:00
EASTERN HERE ON FOX, "LIFE,
LIBERTY, AND LEVINB, THE GREAT
ONE, THINK ME.
WE HAVE A RUSH TO JUDGMENT LOOK
AT BUZZFEED.
WE HAVE A PUSH, NANCY PELOSI
CANNOT EVEN SIT DOWN, SHE IS SO
PULLED TO THE LEFT BY HER PARTY.
THE PRESIDENT HAS GIVEN ON DACA
AND DREAMERS.
EVERYTHING THEY SAY THAT THEY
WANTED, THEY STILL WILL NOT SIT
DOWN WITH HIM HEADING AND YOU
HAVE A LOT OF DEMOCRATS WHO WILL
SEE MORE EIGHT DURING THE
PRESIDENTIAL CAMPAIGN WANTING
70% TAXES AND CONFISCATION OF
WEALTH, WHAT YOU MAKE OF IT ALL?
>> WHAT A MESS.
LET ME START WITH THE MEDIA.
POLL AFTER POLL, SURVEY AFTER
SURVEY SHOWS THAT THE MEDIA ARE
LIBERAL AND DEMOCRAT.
AND THEY DON'T DISAPPOINT TO
LIBERALS AND DEMOCRATS, WE HAVE
A PACKED MEDIA WITH A GROUPTHINK
MENTALITY.
AND I WROTE THIS DOWN BEFORE I
CAME HERE.
THERE ARE NO UNIFORM BINDING
STANDARDS AMONG THE NEWS OUTLET
OUTLETS.
NO CLEAR LINE BETWEEN NEWS AND
OPINION.
THIS IS AN OPINION SHOW.
I GIVE AN OPINION.
YOU GIVE AN OPINION.
BUT NO UNIVERSAL RULES OF
CONDUCT THAT APPLY THE LAWYERS
AND ELECTRICIANS.
NO PARTICULAR EXPERIENCE
REQUIRED TO, CHUCK TODD, CHRIS
CUOMO, THEIR EXPERIENCE AS A
DEMOCRATS HAVE, NO CONNECTING TO
CONNECTIVITY.
NO COMMITMENT TO TRUTH TELLING.
IT IS YELLOW JOURNALISM.
A SCANDALOUS, SENSATIONAL,
INTELLECTUALLY CORRUPT.
SO WHAT WE HAVE IS THE FOURTH OF
THE STATE HAS BECOME THE FIFTH
COLUMN.
MASS MEDIA IN THIS COUNTRY, THEY
ARE COMMITTED TO HILLARY
CLINTON'S ELECTION, NOW
COMMITTED TO OUSTING
DONALD TRUMP.
EVERY SINGLE DAY.
THEY ARE SLOPPY AND THEY MISS
REPORT, THEY DO NOT CARE.
THEY FIGURE THEY WILL THROW OUT
AN APOLOGY IF THEY MUST.
THEY TRY TO DESTROY THE
PRESIDENT, HIS FAMILY, ANYBODY
ASSOCIATED WITH HIM.
HIS STAFF, JUSTICE KAVANAUGH,
ANYTHING.
THEY HAVE NEVER TREATED LIBERAL
DEMOCRATS THIS WAY.
I WILL GIVE YOU A PERFECT
EXAMPLE.
WE WENT TO PENN LEMAN TEN YEARS
OF DONALD TRUMP'S INCOME TAXES.
WHILE I WANT TO TEN YEARS OF THE
NANCY PELOSI IS INCOME TAXES,
SHE IS A MULTIMILLIONAIRE, NO
APPROPRIATION GETS OUT
THROUGHOUT HER, WHY DON'T THEY
CALL FOR HERS AND HOW ABOUT
DIANNE FEINSTEIN?
ALL OF THE INVESTMENTS THAT THEY
HAVE MADE IN RED CHINA.
WE DO NOT HAVE A CHINA SPECIAL
COUNSEL INVESTIGATION TO TALK
ABOUT COLLUSION.
IN THE MEDIA PROMOTES THE
PROGRESSIVE AGENDA.
CLEMENT CHANGE, OPEN BORDERS,
BIG GOVERNMENT.
AND EVERY MILLENNIAL IS SUPPOSED
TO BE ALEXANDRIA OCASIO-CORTEZ.
I DON'T KNOW ANY MILLENNIAL THAT
IS A MARXIST LIKE SHE IS PAID I
KNOW MILLENNIALS WHO VOLUNTEER
TO SERVE IN THE MILITARY WHO ARE
POLICE OFFICERS, WHO ARE
FIREFIGHTERS, WHO ARE DOING
GREAT THINGS FOR THIS
COUNTRY.
EVERY MILLENNIAL IS NOT ON
RADICAL NUT JOB GOING TO THE
SOCIALIST TALKING POINTS.
NOW HER, SHE, WE HAVE TO GET RID
OF THESE BILLIONAIRES.
I'M HAPPY, SO ARE THE STARS, BUT
LET'S TALK THE TRUTH.
IT IS THE AMERICAN DREAM, NOT
THE SOVIET DREAM, JOHN
ROCKEFELLER, WE ARE SUPPOSED TO
HATE HIM.
THANKS TO HIM WE HAVE ENERGY.
NATURAL GAS AND OIL, HE WAS A
MULTIBILLIONAIRE, SO WHAT!
JOHN WALTON, WE HAVE A WALMART
WHERE PEOPLE CAN GET THINGS AT A
DECENT PRICE.
AND THEY EMPLOY TENS OF
THOUSANDS OF AVERAGE AMERICAN
MEN'S.
GREAT, THE FAMILY IS WORTH
BILLIONS, SO WHAT.
WHAT.
WEYERHAEUSER COMING YOU LIKE
TOILET PAPER?
YOU LIKE WRITING PAPER, YOU CAN
THANK WEYERHAEUSER.
BILL GATES, LEFTY, MICROSOFT,
REVOLUTIONIZED COMPUTERS.
ANDREW CARNEGIE, MADE THE
PRODUCTION OF STEEL POSSIBLE
THAT WE USE TODAY.
JEFF BEZOS, I'M NO FAN OF THIS
GUY, BUT CHANGE COMPLETELY HOW
WE BUY.
ANDREW MELLON, FINANCED THE
ELECTRICITY IN EVERY HOME.
I CAN GO ON AND ON.
MULTIBILLIONAIRE'S, WHAT HAS
ALEXANDRIA OCASIO-CORTEZ
CREATED?
ANY JOB, PART-TIME JOB?
HOW ABOUT BERNIE SANDERS, WHAT
HAS HE CREATED?
WHERE'S ALL OF THIS MONEY GOING
TO GO?
70% TAX BRACKET, WHO WILL DECIDE
WHO GETS WHAT?
THE DEPARTMENT OF AGRICULTURE?
THE DEPARTMENT OF ENERGY?
THE EPA?
THEY WASTE $125 BILLION A YEAR
ACCORDING TO THE GAO.
AMERICANS DO NOT LIKE BIG
AUTHORITARIAN CENTRALIZED
GOVERNMENT, AND 2 MILLION
BUREAUCRATS PUSHING THEM AROUND.
SO WHY DO WE CONFER HEALTH CARE
UPON THEM.
AND WHAT DOES SHE KNOW, EXACTLY?
NOTHING.
GO TO THE SUPERMARKET.
THERE IS CAPITALISM.
20 DIFFERENT TYPES OF BREAD.
30 DIFFERENT TYPES OF WINE.
FROM ALL OVER THE WORLD.
FIVE DIFFERENT TYPES OF FISH.
I CANNOT EVEN TELL WHAT FISH, GO
TO THE SUPERMARKET.
LOOK AT ALL OF THE DIFFERENT
THINGS THAT YOU GET.
WE LIVE BETTER.
THEN KINGS AND QUEENS LIVED 1502
THEN KINGS AND QUEENS LIVED 1500
THEN KINGS AND QUEENS LIVED 150Y
THEN KINGS AND QUEENS LIVED 150A
THEN KINGS AND QUEENS LIVED 150S
THEN KINGS AND QUEENS LIVED 150O
THEN KINGS AND QUEENS LIVED 150.
LOOK AT ALL OF THE THINGS AROUND
YOU.
THAT IS CREATED BY CAPITALISM.
CAPITALISM AND FREEDOM,
INDIVIDUALISM.
THE AMERICAN PEOPLE.
THEY ARE ABOUT THE GOVERNMENT,
GOVERNMENT POWER, POWER, THAT'S
WHAT SHE IS ALL ABOUT.
AND MISS OCASIO-CORTEZ, COME ON
MY FOX SHOW ON SUNDAY.
I WANT TO TALK TO YOU.
I WANT TO TALK TO YOU ABOUT
CAPITALISM VERSUS MARXISM AND
SOCIALISM.
I WANT TO TALK TO YOU ABOUT SOME
OF YOUR IDEAS.
I KNOW THAT YOU GO TO THE
SLOBBERING INTERVIEWS AND SO
FORTH.
I PROMISE TO BE RESPECTFUL
PAIRED HAVE ENOUGH GUTS AND
ENOUGH INTELLIGENCE.
BECAUSE MY THEORY, SEAN HANNITY,
IS THIS.
SHE IS A MEDIA CREATION, THAT IS
ALL SHE IS.
AND LET SOME CONSERVATIVES WHO
WILL TREAT HER WITH RESPECT TO
INTERVIEW HER.
I WOULD REQUEST AN INTERVIEW.
>> Sean: GREAT ONE, YOU BETTER
GET IT IN THE NEXT 12 YEARS,
BECAUSE SHE SAYS THE WORLD WILL
END.
I WISH YOU A LOT OF LUCK IN THAT
ENDEAVOR.
I WOULD LOVE TO SEE THE
INTERVIEW.
THAT WAS WHEN YOUR FINEST
MONOLOGUES YOU HAVE EVER GIVEN
ON THE SHOW ABOUT WHAT IS THE
GREATEST ECONOMIC SYSTEM THAT
HAS CREATED MORE FREEDOM, MORE
OPPORTUNITY, MORE WEALTH THAN
ANYONE EVER IMAGINED.
AND WE CAN COMPARE IT TO THOSE
COUNTRIES THAT HAVE CHOSEN THE